good morning to everyone I'm speaking
from London I am an applied machine
learning scientist in Zimmer biomed a
medical device manufacturer and today
I'll talk about a subtle aspect in
hypothesis testing which is assessing if
you have collected enough data for a
significant measurement I'll discuss
pros and cons of a few methods both
frequentist and Bayesian highlighting
one called Precision is the goal uh just
before I start uh I want to mention that
all the slides are available online so
it could follow throughout
um and they'll always be there uh and
all the opinions are my own not of my
employer
um
one of my fondest projects when I
started out my career in data scientist
was something that I call a snail mail a
B test which I considered both a success
and a failure
uh I was working as a consultant for a
mid-sized restaurant chain and they
wanted to see if I could bring in more
new customers through the the doors to
their restaurants then they're competing
marketing firm and I had access to all
the data and I could do and I conducted
in a a b test but it wasn't digital they
sent coupons to people's houses and they
had to redeem in stores so it took me
months to get all the data back uh to
report the results so this success was I
proved to myself and the clients that I
brought in more uh uh people through the
door significantly but my main point of
failure was I I caved to the client's
request to pick before all the data was
in and to give a report and at that
stage the results weren't as impressive
and so that was a beginner's mistake and
I definitely learned from it the fact
that you really want to know when you
should be stopping to report about
results
um so you can know if your results are
significant or not I think that's an
overlooked Topic in the hypothesis
testing and so that's what we're going
to be talking about today I did the
common thing what I think most
practitioners do is do some power
calculation and then totally forget
about your inputs in that calculation
when you extract the number n to report
for um whoever you know does the budget
for the experiment and then just I uh
wing it from there on but there is a
better approach something that I came
across reading the and hearing the
material from a statistician named John
krusk you can read all about it in his
book so my main points here are taken
from this chapter 13.3 uh I myself have
been doing uh analysis in research
research for over 15 years I started off
as an astronomer and most recently I've
been working within the health sector uh
two main take-home messages from today
um the most common methods both
frequencies and bayesians something that
I call a threshold stop Criterion they
yield but they can't yield biased
results uh a much better
um method is the focus of this talk
Precision is the goal where the focus is
predetermining what the Precision should
be and then you'll get reliable results
the trade-off of course is it might be
slightly more expensive but then again
you'll get reliable results so that's it
in terms of motivation I don't assume
that everybody knows what hypothesis
test is so I'll give a gentle
introduction to that and then I'll talk
about the main problem with the current
uh frequentest in Bayesian methods and
I'll talk about John crisp's uh
Precision is the goal now I was quite
excited that while I Was preparing this
talk and coding things up I actually
made a mistake and came across a
possible Improvement to Precision is the
goal and so I'm very excited to
introduce that as well later on
um so let's start talking about what is
hypothesis testing and why is stopping a
critical aspect of it hypothesis testing
is when you collect data in order to
achieve a certain goal for example you
want to reject another hypothesis or
rather confirm your underlying beliefs
and there are many examples of that for
example in drug development
polling data you want to know which
candidate will win and before I talked
about marketing so I can think of a b
tests and are you very useful analogy
for all these cases is uh coin fairness
when you have two values success or
failure so we'll be using that
throughout the demonstration today the
key challenge of hypothesis testing is
that most likely you'll not be able to
have a budget to probe your whole
population but rather you'll use a
sample a useful analogy is taking a
sample from soup while you're making it
in our household we like using lentils
and so those are on the bottom so if you
don't put the ladle all the way in the
bottle you'll get a misrepresentative
sample right you might think well we
don't have uh uh lentils and so that you
might get in incorrect conclusions and
of course the language of communicating
samples is via statistics who can tell
you what to expect in terms of means and
variances Etc one of the main challenges
is that stakeholders want both reliable
results but they want it fast Adam
meaning at a minimal cost and so that's
a trade-off that every analyst has to
balance and there might be even more
challenges like for example clinicians
might want to stop a test as soon as
possible for example if they're looking
at drug development uh they want to
avoid like deleterious effects as soon
as possible and so we constantly have
this trade-off between accuracy and
speed and that will cause people to want
to peek into their data but the caution
there is that that might result in
biased interpretation uh it's something
that's called confirmation bias like
you'll confirm what you thought
beforehand
um incorrectly uh and so that's what
we'll see manifest both in the
frequencies null hypothesis significance
test and the Bayesian uh
so by far the most popular method is the
nhst uh for the reason is it's fairly
easy to calculate
uh all practitioners are familiar with
it there are many in many textbooks and
software packages uh but there are cons
to it first of all it's not not
intuitive for non-experts
um and so it does raise a lot of
confusion uh one of which is that uh
with the nhst you can only reject the
null hypothesis you can never accept it
um
yesterday actually uh so one question I
was most interested in is why can't we
why can't the nhst accept the null
hypothesis
um it's stated but nobody uh I haven't
seen an answer for why that is it's
beyond the scope of this talk but
yesterday I did deliver a lightning talk
so if you're interested it's already on
the YouTube channel and I also have
slides here available in which you can
go through that
um and for that reason actually
um I um if you go to the slide that uh
of this talk you'll see I have all the
material for mhxt but uh for the sake of
time uh I'm going to focus on Beijing uh
mostly because of this reason because
the pre-values uh you cannot accept the
null hypothesis when Bayesian you can uh
to drive my points I'm going to like I
said focus on on coin flip tests and
um and there isn't for that uh oh and
what I'm going to look at as it is in
sequential hypothesis testing meaning
we're going to just toss a coin over and
over until we get to of some threshold
and then we'll stop or to some stopping
criteria and they will stop and the
reason for this is for Simplicity
we're going to use Bernal distributions
statistics which are well defined and
you can use analytical Solutions which
makes life really easy uh and so what I
mean by tossing coins well we'll look
both at a Fair coin where the under
underlying parameter the parameter of
interest is the success rate where
that's going to be
um set up true of 0.5 which is something
that we have the privilege of knowing
because we're running the simulations in
real life you don't have access to this
information that's what you you're
running your hypothesis for uh but we'll
also compare versus uh unfair coin
trials at 65 where they're supposed to
be where that means we're looking at
something with a lot of signal uh so
let's first look at the uh uh at a
popular Bayesian approach called HDI
with rope I'll introduce what high
density interval and and region and
practical equivalence actually means and
then we'll talk about the results of
sequential uh coin flipping and what
we'll say is that the Bayesian the fact
that we're doing something Bayesian it
doesn't magically correct for all the
problems that there are with the nhsd
um
uh and that's why I'll show like why
it's still my my yield bias results so
first of all what is it uh the high
density interval is a way of a
quantifying a credible uh uh a credible
interval like you have it doesn't matter
what the shape of your posterior is it
could be anything and what you do is you
scan from top to bottom until you get
let's say 95 of the mass and then just
draw the the parameters of that so
that's called the HDI and so uh we'll
use that and we'll compare it to
something that we call a region of
practical equivalence here I'm just
quoting from from John Chris's book but
effectively it means take your null
value and depending on your domain and
whatever you're measuring uh you have to
be realistic with yourself like how much
do you really care about differences do
you really care about a 0.1 percent or
can you be more lenient between minus
five to five percent it's really domain
specific and that's what you define as
your rope what are your most what's the
region that you're interested in looking
to see if you significantly Beyond on
because you don't really care about
small minute changes within so that's a
key aspect so the the
um the
um
uh the algorithm for the stock criteria
and from HCA in rope is collect data
until the HDI is completely uh within
the Rope like this example or it's
completely without outside of the Rope
like this example over here so in this
case we'll accept the null hypothesis in
this case we'll reject the null
hypothesis these are actually two out of
six uh cases uh for completeness I'll
show all the six cases so the two in
which you'll reject this is what I've
shown before to the right and then you
have also to the left uh and
um there's one scenario for accepting
what I showed before if it's fully in
but then we have three
um cases in which will actually be
inconclusive we don't know if to reject
or not so that might suggest we'll just
want to collect more data and so that's
if you're straddling to the left strut
the HDI straddles to the right of the
Rope or straddles both sides other
meaning it's too wide within the group
itself
uh okay so
let's look at one example let's look at
an example of one experiment in which
we're just tossing a coin over and over
uh let's say that we can go to 1 500
times let's say we're using a Fair coin
so here you here this dashed line shows
the ground truth I purposely chose an
example in which it starts off really
negative so everything in red means a
negative toss and this statistic here on
top is the is the average of the
cumulative sum so
um
so again it's binary tosses and I'm just
taking the average of the cumulative
until that point so you can see around
200 it's fairly negative again it's an
extreme case
um and then eventually
um and then it climbs up eventually if
you do it you know
um very much so like like thousand
thousand eventually you'll get to this
line over here
um but of course you have limited
budgets so you wouldn't know it and what
I'm plotting down here is the x-axis is
the same it's a trial number but here
I'm actually applying the HDI the width
and the first thing that you notice is
the width starts very large because you
don't have much data and then it starts
narrowing down and also I plotted here
um the Rope so here the Min value the
max value and you want and what you want
to see in the stock Criterion is
um where does the HDI go outside or
inside or if it's a stroller like over
here it's straddling and so that's why
you're collecting more data and then and
the first time that it's actually within
inside is here at Point uh toss number
912 and so then you'll accept Okay then
most of the time in most algorithms what
you'll do is you'll stop the experiment
um then in there but just for
completeness I'm sure what happens if
you actually go beyond you see suddenly
uh you're inconclusive until you get a
few more and then you see you accept All
the Way Forward which is the correct
thing to do right you have
um fed up it is a Fair coin so you
should be accepting okay so this is only
one example how representative is this
well then so for this purpose uh I ran
thousands of the same experiment where
in each experiment I I literally I stuff
like here I'll stop at at 912. I'll also
mention briefly mention the the nhst the
frequentest approach will actually stop
at 342. so around over here the reason
is because of there's so many negative
results setting a p-value threshold of
let's say five percent that will be the
stock criteria and it would incorrectly
reject the null hypothesis at 352. okay
so like I said that's in I have a full
stack of slides I have material worth of
45 to 60 minutes but here I'm trying to
keep it short so I'm focusing on the on
on Bayesian
okay so this figure here explains uh um
results for thousands of experiments
like the one I showed before so just to
show like how this is representative so
I can best explain uh this figure and
understand this figures keep
understanding the the uh all the
arguments that follow so I'll do my best
to break it down so the x-axis is the
same it's the number of iterations but
now uh the y-axis is the rate of the
decision being made what decisions do we
have what we said before we can either
accept the null hypothesis reject it or
inconclusive the sum of the green red
and gray is a hundred percent at each at
each point and and what does each point
mean so let's focus for example um uh we
talked about here we stopped at 9 912 so
if I'm pulling up 912 over here just
about and so at 912 that means if the
experiment got to 900 if your experiment
stopped at 912 or before right it could
stop before then about 60 percent of
time you accept the null hypothesis at
912. unfortunately 20 of the time you
would have rejected the null hypothesis
and whatever is left you're inconclusive
because it's still struggling and so
this is interesting because you are
doing the correct thing most of the time
you are accepting but you can't see an
asymptot here at 20 percent which is
very alarming that you're incorrectly
rejecting the null hypothesis and the
reason for that is that uh over here we
run into extreme cases in which you
happen to have a whole lot of classes
that are are radically outside of the
rope and he just rejected it and so
that's uh I mean flaw with this Bayesian
method called HDI plus rope so
um let's so before we looked at a Fair
coin now let's look at at a a an unfair
coin and so here you can see it's doing
the job uh fairly quickly it's rejecting
the null hypothesis and it barely ever
accepts the null hypothesis and that's
what that's what you're expecting that's
what you want and it does so after like
200 passes it rejects the null
hypothesis but there is still a problem
and which you cannot see over here and
what you see over here and this figure
is also crucial to understand the main
arguments uh for today is the fact that
what upon here is a histogram of what's
the sample success rate at the point of
the decision
uh so
it's the mean should be around 0.65
because that's the true underlying truth
but what you can see is that the mean of
this distribution as 0.72 and the reason
is obvious you can see it over here is
that you hold have a whole lot this
extreme cases on the positive side uh
and so that skews the results and why is
that dangerous because a lot of times
you'll show results to a stakeholder and
they'll think that well let's say that
you that you happen to get a result here
at 90 and then you stakeholder will
think oh that's representative of the
sample the sample uh is the result of
our test is 90 likely to succeed but
that's incorrect because the the
underlying truth is 65 but you ran only
experiment one experiment and so you get
one of these for example
um
and so that's the main that's the main
floor with HDI plus rope uh in terms of
you're dealing with an unfair coin so
with the Fair coin the the problem is
rejecting uh incorrectly rejecting 20 of
the time and with The Fair coin even
though you're doing the correct thing
rejecting or accept in terms of
rejecting but uh you're you're you're
likely to have a population that is um
unrepresentative of the ground truth so
how could so
um so the takeaway from the Beijing HDI
plus rope is uh you can't avoid nhst by
the way has similar uh uh problems and
so
um if
but if some people think that oh just do
everything Beijing that will magically
correct for everything hence the fairies
uh well that's incorrect um you won't be
able to uh get over the main cause of
nhst uh even though it does have uh uh
advantages over over the frequencies
approach is in the sense that a you
can't accept the null hypothesis you
have a much more descriptive credible
interval and uh you may add prior
beliefs which is beyond the scope of
this talk but my main point is you it it
it's worth the overhead to go Bayesian
most of the time if you can afford it uh
but
um but you we can actually do better
than HDI plus rope and that's uh um
Precision is the goal which actually
it's very similar to HDI plus Europe uh
except for one key aspect is that the
focus is on the HDI width but not on its
location what do I mean by that well
what I mean is that what you'll want to
do is you want to Define what's how
precise do you want your measure to be
and you want to do this before the
experiment so a common practice is just
take whatever ever your rope is and just
decide like the Precision around it
normally uh what's common to do is like
take 80 percent so that's the decision
that's the Precision and so the
algorithm for precision is the goal is
collect data until the width of the HDI
is smaller than the Precision again no
mention of where the null hypothesis is
you're not adding that information when
you're determining
on the stock Criterion and then uh the
the decision making is the same if it's
totally within you except if it's
totally out you reject and then of
course if it straddles you're still
inconclusive so similar okay so let's
examine the results so let's start off
actually with the unfair coin where here
you can see that it's doing the correct
thing it's rejecting it's taking a bit
longer later I'll do one-to-one
experiments comparison you can see it
takes a bit longer to get there it still
doesn't accept incorrectly the null
hypothesis but what's impressive about
it is this figure that this figure now
here you can see the true rate of uh the
the the mean of of the uh of the sample
when
um
the sample success rate at the the point
of the making decision actually
perfectly overlaps with the true rate
and so that's what you expect so that
means they could go to the stakeholder
and say hey I this is uh uh uh um
representative of the population up to
some
um you know up to some variants and so
that that's a that's a great thing to
have that makes it much more reliable
um but there is one main flaw that I've
identified uh is that if so so this is
the main advantage of uh you know the
unfair coin the Fair coin has that same
Advantage except for um well I'll start
with actually the positive the the main
advantage for the Fair coin is that it
never rejects incorrectly rejects the
null hypothesis if you remember before
with HDI plus rope we had
um it incorrectly rejected at 20 but now
it's it's never incorrectly rejecting
the null hypothesis
um uh and it is accepting the null
hypothesis but the only negative thing I
can say is that it's not doing so
um too frequently it's actually stopping
short of of 40 in in the example that I
chose over here it's highly inconclusive
and so
um well what does that mean uh what it
shows as well collecting more data won't
help you'll just have to make some sort
of uh decision based on confidence and
uh from their own and so Precision is
the goal yields accurate results which
which is a massive feather in its cap um
the only black eye for improvement is
that what to do
um when the underlying
um if they're not hypothesis happens to
be the truth which you don't know that
and you have to deal somehow with
inconclusive outcomes that really
depends on the question and the domain
and it's a bit beyond the scope of this
talk
um so I was um so I Was preparing this
talk a while ago and um we have a
newborn in our house uh and she was
lying on me and I was coding up on the
scripts in Python and
um I actually did a
a mistake and it was a fortunate
mistake because I actually realized that
it could slightly improve on Precision
is the goal of something that I call
conservative Precision is the goal and
uh because it actually it hasn't
improved dealing with those inconclusive
results that I showed before and so I'll
just present the algorithm itself but
it's actually
not that's too too sophisticated I'm
basically taking both algorithms and I
mash them together by accident but it
actually uh um uh gave pleasantly
surprising results so what what do I
mean by that well you collect data until
uh you both
um
but collected until the HDI is less than
Precision is the goal that's the main
method we're talking about and we have
the original algorithm from HDI plus
rope if the HDI is completely within the
Rope or outside of the Rope so just
combining both methods together
um what I what I show here is it yields
better results
um so just to break it down
um this might be look overwhelming but
if you understand the previous plots I'm
just copy pasted them over here where
here's the new results so just to run
you buy it here you can see ATA plus
rope the main problem was we're reject
with with The Fair coin we're rejecting
the null hypothesis incorrectly 20 of
the time and then we correct it for that
with with Precision is the goal but it's
highly inconclusive and with
conservative Precision is the goal you
can see we never we never incorrectly
reject it in the hypothesis But
ultimately we will accept the uh uh the
null hypothesis correctly just as we did
here here and actually add some tons to
one uh the main trade-off is it's just
slightly more expensive at doing so so
that's in if you're underlying uh uh uh
if the null hypothesis is your
underlying truth what happens if it's
not your underlying Truth uh well then
it's
um
so then uh uh the conservative is
similar to Precision is a goal and
always rejecting ultimately which takes
it slightly more time than HDI plus rope
but you can see you're never accepting
the null hypothesis
um well actually this did it but it just
takes longer but it's worthwhile for uh
considering uh this trade-off because
you don't know what your underlying
truth is
uh one problem and all the methods is
what happens when uh when the result is
traveling and so
um yeah I I don't know if there's
anything one can do about that but just
make an educated guess about you know
how to make a decision given this
inconclusiveness so it doesn't solve for
it so um yeah okay just to summarize
um what what uh what we've been talking
about today so take home messages is
that the common methods of the stop
criteria that I call threshold both
frequentness and Bayesian
um have mate lead biased results uh due
to sensitivity to uh uh uh extreme
samples that might uh pop up where
Precision is the goal is uh Wheels
reliable results for the main reason
that uh you're determining your
Precision in advance so you know what to
expect for the main trade-off is it's
not likely to be more expensive and so
you should budget for it but your
stakeholders will get a more reliable
result and that's what you want at the
end of the day right accuracy uh is a
function of cost
um there's many topics that I I brushed
over today I did look into for example
uh oh I didn't talk about inconclusive
results how to deal with them that's
demands and domains I didn't talk about
power calculations again you can like
engineer this to to do your own power
calculations
um
Basin use of suppliers of course is very
useful
um
uh multiple hypothesis comparisons it
has an impact on frequencies as far as I
know it doesn't impact Bayesian
um I dealt today with only analytical
Solutions meaning I could use like side
Pi algorithms if you need a numerical
solution you want to use something like
Pi MC again beyond the scope of this
talk and stratification for for cohorts
so uh just to summarize the common
threshold of the common methods frequent
is ambition of threshold stop criterions
yield bias results pursues that goal
um is meals more reliable results but at
the cost of um having inconclusive
results that need to be dealt with and I
introduced conservative uh Precision is
the goal as a possible uh uh Improvement
uh and so just before I I finished to
take questions uh two plugins for other
talks yesterday I talked about I I gave
a talk about uh causal inference and why
it's a useful tool to have in your
statistical toolbar bucks so you can get
more of your data and avoid
misinterpretation of your data so I
presented that yesterday all the slides
are available online and another talk
that I presented in in pi data 22 is how
to deal how to optimize when you have
more if you have two or more objectives
in mind for example if you're comparing
quality versus price and you don't know
the true relationship between them and
you have scattered results like this why
is it that you should choose these as
equally optimal results from which you
want to sub select from so it's a very
interesting topic called Pareto fronts
and it will help you improve your
decision making again all the slides are
available online and actually I have a
Hands-On tutorial with Jupiter notebooks
um
so with that I'll thank you for your
time and take questions from here
thank you we have quite a few questions
but you only have time for one I'm gonna
ask folks to uh post these questions on
the Discord uh where the speaker can
answer
um or yeah if you have time you can
maybe drop into the YouTube chat after
this and answer these questions let's
take uh let's take this one
where these are asks what about the
opposite question went another when to
know that the null hypothesis is
rejected is there any equivalent in this
framework that like to ahead of time
sample size estimates that's power of
the experiment
okay I'm just trying to uh understand
the question itself
I mean you don't want to advance if
you're going to reject or
um if I understand it question correctly
you don't know in advance if you're
going to reject or you're going to
accept that's that's the whole
um what we're trying to figure out the
objective of precision is the goal is
determining how precise you want your
measurement to be and then whatever
comes comes you'll have three decisions
to make either you'll accept or you'll
reject or you'll be inconclusive because
it might be straddling the Rope so you
don't know in advance what you're going
to do you let the data speak for itself
uh and uh just the emphasis is that you
if you use a standard nhst or the most
common uh Bayesian methods like uh I
presented only one um HDI plus rope you
are uh there is it's like a possibility
that you'll get um you'll get incorrect
results and that's um what John Cruz is
trying to uh portray with uh the
importance of predetermining your
precision as opposed to winning it kind
of at the end uh I don't know if that
answers the the question but um that's
my best attempt